you ever given up on a script because
you just lost interest here and there
you know I I generally don't start
writing something unless I have done
enough outlining and enough enough
exploration of the idea to know it's
worth going to script
yeah particular if I'm writing something
on spec there are definitely things I've
written on spec that I've stuff few
things I've started and for some reason
I've just sort of abandoned because I I
felt like if I can go back and finish
this sometime if I want to but it's not
great enough it's not going to be unique
enough so it becomes a bit of an
exercise but by and large I've always
tried not to start writing something
unless I was unless I felt it was
something I was gonna be able to finish
or that it was weren't really worth
doing it's like reading a book you know
it's like I tried if I'm reading a book
if I'm if I go to the trouble of
starting to read it I might as well
finish it you know but unless an idea is
terrible you know we don't always have
great ideas sometimes this is just not
enough there but you can I usually know
that in the outline stage to save me the
you know the the the hardship of writing
the script and the you know having it
sort of like kill it basically so what
if you meet with a writer that's you
know new to the industry or you know
baby writer whenever you want to call
and they just have a slew of unfinished
scripts well there's a reason you have a
slew of unfinished scripts you know you
you need especially if we started enough
writing you need one or two good solid
finished scripts so when I hear somebody
has a slew of unfinished scripts it
means that they're really not picking
and choosing their their stories well
you know that they're really not they're
not passionate enough about the story or
they're they're cheating themselves
about about what the story is about or
they're trying to just you know write a
thriller because they think that's going
to sell or something like that yeah and
and a lot of people start writing
without having the tools the necessary
tools you know everybody thinks oh I can
write you know but they don't really
understand structure they don't really
understand I'm not saying you have to
take a course in it or whatever but you
know you you you have to you know have
done your homework
you know in one way or another and
understand how to tell a story
cinematically or for television and not
everybody has done that some people just
jump in and they're not really ready
you